this is the biggest obstacle to rescue
operations in earthquake hit areas huge
chunks of rocks fallen from the
mountains block roads we stop here while
the Army warn against the danger of
further Rock
slides after 6 hours on the road we
finally make it to tattin yakob a
village 90 kilm South of
maresh a frantic search is underway for
those still trapped under the
rubble
Muhammad lost nine members of his family
in the
earthquake it breaks my heart I lost my
daughter she was very young her children
are gone we're waiting for one other
let's pray he's
alive Muhammad's grandchild was
retrieved a lifeless body a life taken
too
soon he will be buried near his parents
in the village
Cemetery these doctors from the city of
Casablanca are volunteering to help
victims we're dealing mainly with
victims of trauma people suffering
serious injuries when buildings
collapsed on them we treat minor
injuries in makeshift clinics here but
critical ones are sent to the
city the Army has reached here
delivering Aid setting up makeshift
clinics and helping the rescue
operation this is one of many cases
which illustrate the delicate task ahead
for The Rescuers Medical Teams and the
authorities this lady is going to be now
flown to the city of Marakesh where
she's going to be treated and the Army
is deploying its helicopters to the
epicenter of the earthquake and all the
villages which were affected by the
Quake it's a Race Against Time to find
people still trapped under the rub hash
Al jaaz platin yakob south of
Marakesh make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler